vous me faites très très peur pour la
jeunesse pour je souhaite vraiment
je vais vous montrer que
je suis pour la liberté et autant que
femme si je veux me pointer à 7h du
matin sexy je me pointe à 7h du matin
sexy je vais vous montrer tout de suite
merci
juste je pense que vous allez je pense
que vous allez avoir un appel de Gilles
Verdez
pas
il y a des lieux merci non je suis là je
suis là
[Applaudissements]
ça y est moi je pars en principe en
France on peut
un territoire français
à liberté merci alors bravo et si tu
pouvais prêter ton soutien-gorge
Benjamin merci merci
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez on va on va revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé vraiment l'actualité du jour
merci Ruby
habillez vous aussi